chances are during the pandemic your
kids have probably learned a lot more
about
finances whether you've been challenged
by being out of work or just wanted to
make sure your money is going farther
financial experts say you can start
talking to your kids about finances
as early as three years old kirsten
joyce joins us with some more financial
tips
well brian a recent study done at
university of cambridge found money
habits can be formed
as early as seven years of age and the
conversations to have with your kids can
be more just about finding the everyday
financial lesson like when you head to
the grocery store this evening to buy
dinner
instead of just grabbing the salad bag
and putting it in your cart
tell your child i only have x amount of
money to spend
i'm choosing this salad bag because
it's a it's not a brand name and it's
cheaper
or maybe it's a there's a discount on it
that way
or perhaps it's as easy as uh
it's a buy one get one free and that's
why you're making that decision so it's
really about
choosing the everyday financial lessons
that you can communicate to your child
at a young age
banking editor alexis serrano with
finder.com says you'll want to change
the way you talk to your children about
money as they age
now when it comes to savings a lot of
parents start their kids with a piggy
bank
but alexis says that actually might
confuse your children she says instead
get
three piggy banks or jars one for
savings
one for spending and the third jar for
sharing or charity
and that way you're already teaching
your child the concept of keeping your
savings and spending
separate from each other denise